Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
manscape luego os doy más detalles pero
antes vamos con nuestra historia de hoy
[Música]
[Aplausos]
os voy a hacer una pregunta cuál diríais
que es el mejor Aliado de China es decir
el país más importante en estos momentos
en la geopolítica del gigante asiático
seguramente todos tengáis la respuesta
Corea del Norte
[Música]
Y sí tenéis razón Corea del Norte es el
único país con quien China tiene una
alianza militar desde 1961 es decir que
al menos en teoría si alguien atacará
china Corea del Norte tendría que salir
en su defensa y viceversa pero por lo
demás seamos honestos Beijing Lleva años
distanciandose de pyongyang vamos a ser
claros en realidad Corea del Norte no
tienen nada que ofrecer a China Más allá
de dolores de cabeza pero eso es otra
historia para otro vídeo Lo cierto es
que no hay ningún medidor objetivo de la
amistad pero sí podemos encontrar
algunas cifras que ayudan a entender lo
bien que se llevan unos países con otros
por ejemplo el comercio de armas
pensadlo así un estado solo vende armas
a un país en el que confía y la pregunta
es quién es el principal importador de
armas chinas Pues atentos esta gráfica
porque os va a sorprender
Exacto estamos hablando de Pakistán para
que os hagáis una idea el 40% de todas
las armas que china vendió entre 2016 y
2020 fueron a parar a este país pero no
creáis que hablamos solamente de armas
china es el acreedor del 30% de toda la
deuda externa de Pakistán de hecho china
está construyendo tanto un corredor
comercial como un puerto en este país
estas dos infraestructuras podrían ser
cruciales para la seguridad y la
economía china Pero de eso vamos a
hablar más adelante en el vídeo de hoy
Porque por otro lado Pakistán es uno de
los países más inestables de todo Asia
como ya hemos visto aquí en
visualpolitik este país está al borde de
la quiebra económica y eso es
preocupante si tenemos en cuenta que
tienen bombas atómicas y además una
doctrina nuclear de gatillo fácil pero
es que no solo eso también tienen más de
40 grupos terroristas
[Música]
Sí sí habéis oído bien Pakistán es el
hogar de alrededor de 45 grupos
terroristas distintos dicho de otra
forma que es todo un avispero y a la vez
es un Aliado cada vez más importante de
China podríamos decir que es el mejor
aéreo de Beijing Pues de nuevo no existe
un medidor objetivo de la amistad pero
desde luego podemos decir que es uno de
sus aliados más importantes y a la vez
más inestables la pregunta es por qué
hasta qué punto estas relaciones son un
problema para occidente puede china
acabar de una vez por todas con el
terrorismo en Pakistán hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
este año la Navidad se ha adelantado en
visualpolitik acabamos de recibir el
performance 4.0 de manscape vamos a
echarle un vistazo este kit de higiene
afeitado de manscape cubre todas tus
necesidades desde la cabeza hasta los
pies literalmente para empezar incluye
la Joya de la corona la recortadora
impermeable inalámbrica laund mower 4.0
con su tecnología avanzada skin save que
nos ayuda a evitar Cortes y enganchones
en las zonas más sensibles del cuerpo
viene con una luz led muy práctica a la
hora de afeitarse en esas noches fría
muy oscuras de invierno Además este kit
incluye también el with waker la
recortadora para el vello de la nariz y
las orejas con cuchillas giratorias de
360 grados en el momento en el que
empieces de usarla te darás cuenta de
que no sabrás vivir sin ella pero esto
no es todo además en este kit
encontrarás el desodorante íntimo Cross
server y el spray tónico crop reviver y
además por si todo esto fuera poco
también recibiréis dos regalos esta
bolsa de seo y este boxer de manscape
antirraduras pero esperad un momento
porque ahora viene lo mejor si vais a
manscape.com y utilicéis el código vps
conseguiréis un 20% de descuento más
elemento internacional gratuito además
de estos dos regalos encontraréis todos
los detalles en la descripción y ahora
sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
iría cuervos y te sacarán los ojos
Pakistán es uno de los 7 instanes es
decir esos siete países cuyo nombre
termina en Instant ahora bien sabéis De
dónde viene exactamente el nombre de
este país pues aunque no lo parezca es
un acrónimo estos nombres que veis por
aquí son las principales etnias que
conviven en Pakistán p de afgania K de
sasmire y tan de palo chistán Ya lo sé
no es un acrónimo perfecto pero es que
paquisbeth sonaba un poco mal en
cualquier caso el nombre de Pakistán es
muy significativo si tenemos en cuenta
su historia y aquí es cuando nos tenemos
que remontar muy atrás en el tiempo
antes incluso de que llegaran los
colonos británicos
[Música]
veréis lo que hoy conocemos como
Pakistán estaba dividido entre
diferentes grupos étnicos dicho de otra
forma No existía ningún sentimiento de
pertenencia a una nación llamada
Pakistán esto era un territorio poblado
por distintas etnias que tenía muy poco
que ver entre ellas el grupo más grande
era el punjavi pero también estaban los
pastunes los indies los saraikies o
balochis en el territorio cada grupo de
más hablaba diferentes lenguas por
ejemplo los pun ya había hablaban y
Siguen hablando urdu que es además la
lengua oficial de Pakistán de repente
llegaron los británicos y colonizaron
todo lo que ahora es Pakistán India y
bangladesh un Mosaico gigantesco de
Culturas y etnias distintas después
estos territorios se independizaron tras
varias guerras terminamos teniendo lo
que ahora conocemos como Pakistán un
intento de crear una nación juntando
distintas etnias vamos a decirlo claro
con calzador conclusión Pakistán nunca
ha resuelto sus tensiones étnicas y
religiosas y ya sé lo que os estaréis
preguntando muchos pero por qué Pakistán
se lleva tan mal con la India Pues
precisamente por uno de esos conflictos
religiosos
en este caso hablamos de la región de
kashmir cuando el Imperio británico
llegó al territorio decidió dar el poder
de kashmir a un grupo étnico hinduista
minoritario los dogras este grupo purgó
a todos los musulmanes que estaban en el
poder en jazmir si tenemos en cuenta que
el 95% de la población era musulmana os
podéis imaginar que no les hizo la más
mínima gracia sin embargo el punto de
quiebra llegó con la independencia de
India y Pakistán en el año 1947 Pakistán
reclamaba este territorio pero el
gobernador de la zona decidió integrarse
en la India desde entonces estos dos
países se odian a muerte
pero esperad un momento porque este es
solo uno de los muchísimos conflictos
que tiene Pakistán hoy en día las
tensiones entre las distintas etnias que
componen este país No han terminado
nunca y diréis Pero por qué es por una
cuestión religiosa por una cuestión
racial pues no del todo la principal
razón es la economía o más bien la
desigual distribución de los recursos
[Música]
veréis en Pakistán los recursos del
estado se dirigen a las diferentes
provincias dependiendo del número de
personas que vivan en cada una de ellas
Claro si tenemos en cuenta que la
provincia de punjar tiene unos 110
millones de personas que es casi la
mitad de la población total de Pakistán
que son unos 220 millones la mitad de
todos los recursos van a esta región Y
si esto lo unimos que los punjavis son
mayoría en el parlamento y que van a
intentar favorecer siempre los intereses
de su región y de su etnia tenemos el
cóctel perfecto para un conflicto étnico
[Música]
por ejemplo los erikis viven en el sur
de punjah y se quejan de que no les
llegan recursos Pero los pastunes que
también están en este país también se
quejan de lo mismo de que no les llegan
recursos pero sin duda alguna el estado
más desamparado es balochistan en el sur
del país para los chistán es la región
más grande en territorio pero solo un 5%
de la población vive por aquí por eso
también es la región que menos recursos
recibe pero no sólo eso los punja que
viven en esta región se hicieron con
muchas de las tierras que pertenecían a
los balochis Además desde la capital del
país islamabad han intervenido en la
política regional con mano de hierro
conclusión en el año 2000 nació un grupo
terrorista que es el ejército de
liberación de balochista desde entonces
es normal encontrarse con noticias como
esta el ejército de liberación de
balochistán reivindica El Atentado de
karachi y la primera mujer suicida la
explosión arrasó una furgoneta en el
interior de la Universidad de karachi en
el sur de Pakistán el Bla afirmó que el
atentado fue perpetrado por una mujer
suicida Exacto todos estos conflictos
étnicos han dado un enorme catálogo de
grupos terroristas pero por si esto
fuera poco el ejército de Pakistán ha
apoyado a muchos de estos grupos y
diréis venga ya Fonseca Pero qué interés
puede tener el ejército de un país Para
apoyar a grupos terroristas la respuesta
está en la India el archienemigo de
Pakistán el ejército de paquistaní tiene
una estrategia muy curiosa para luchar
contra la India una estrategia que
además tiene un nombre muy descriptivo y
a la vez poético de sangrar a la India
con mil Cortes
esta estrategia consiste en apoyar
grupos Insurgentes dentro de la India
para desestabilizarla desde entonces Nos
encontramos con decenas de grupos
terroristas en hombre impronunciable que
operan en kashmir las caretaiba
heathbull
entre otros por ejemplo las caretaiba es
el responsable de los mayores ataques
terroristas que ha sufrido la India
incluyendo el atentado de mumbai de 2008
donde murieron 170 personas
Y qué problema tiene esta estrategia
para Pakistán pues simple y llanamente
cría cuervos que te sacarán los ojos
fijaos en estas cifras como ya os podéis
imaginar financiar grupos terroristas es
un arma de doble filo ahora Pakistán es
una víspero con decenas de grupos
armados y montones de víctimas y no solo
hablamos de un problema de seguridad
también se trata de un problema
económico porque a fin de cuentas quién
va a montar empresas en un país donde en
cualquier momento le pueden poner una
bomba pero de la economía de Pakistán ya
hemos hablado en vídeos anteriores ahora
vamos a hablar de un actor muy
importante en el desarrollo del
terrorismo pakistaní Y diréis de quién
estamos hablando pues nada más y nada
menos que de Estados Unidos y diréis
cómo pero qué interés tiene Washington
en financiar grupos terroristas en
Pakistán Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el legado de John Rambo
los que no estéis en la generación Z y
hayáis pasado Ya la treintena
recordaréis la saga de películas de
Rambo verdad y seguro que muchos habréis
visto Rambo 3 Pues bien entre explosión
y explosión esta película tiene bastante
más geopolítica de lo que os
imaginaríais en este film Rambo
interpretado por Sylvester Stallone va a
entrenar a los guerreros muyaidines que
luchan contra la unión soviética en
Afganistán justo al lado de Pakistán
eran los años 80 y en aquella época los
comunistas eran los malos de la película
nunca Mejor dicho y todos los que se
enfrentarán contra ellos eran los héroes
Y sí ese incluía a estos Héroes de la
libertad que defendían sus tradiciones
milenarias frente a los malvados
comunistas Pues bien esta película
refleja un hecho que realmente ocurrió
durante la Guerra Fría la muy religiosa
Pakistán se alineó con los Estados
Unidos para luchar contra la pea unión
soviética y así es como Washington se
convirtió en el mayor proveedor de armas
de Pakistán y entrenador de terroristas
de hecho para que os hagáis una idea
hasta 1965 Pakistán importaba el 70% de
sus armas del Tío Sam a partir de
entonces las relaciones entre países
fueron a peor en el 65 Washington puso
un embargo a la venta de armas tanto la
India como a Pakistán y en cuanto a
Pakistán empezó su programa nuclear El
Tío Sam ha bloqueado más y más envíos de
armas
no obstante a principios de nuestro
siglo parecía que la amistad entre estos
dos países se podría recuperar y diréis
por qué Pues porque tras el 11 de
septiembre Estados Unidos declaró la
guerra contra el terror Osama Bin Laden
de repente se convirtió en el hombre más
buscado del mundo y como pensaban que se
escondían Afganistán Estados Unidos
pidió ayuda a la vecina Pakistán Y qué
pidieron los pakistanías a cambio
evidentemente el levantamiento de
sanciones comerciales ayuda económica
directa y un largo etcétera de preventas
podréis pensar que Pakistán salió
ganando pero lo cierto Es que nunca
dejaron de quejarse porque los aviones
estadounidenses volaban el espacio aéreo
pakistaní pensadlo bien estaban buscando
Bin Laden sin embargo lo que terminó por
romper las relaciones entre estos dos
países fue precisamente el momento en el
que encontraron a Bin Laden si recordáis
Bin Laden estaba escondido en una de las
ciudades más ricas de Pakistán
concretamente estaba viviendo en un
chalet y llevaba viviendo ahí durante
años vamos que solo le faltó poner un
león luminoso aquí en la puerta diciendo
Aquí vive Bin Laden vengan a buscarme
cómo es posible que el ejército
pakistaní no se diera cuenta O tal vez
hicieron la vista gorda como
comprenderéis después de esto Estados
Unidos se ha mantenido un poco frío
frente a Pakistán Y con toda la razón
del mundo no nos vamos a engañar y el
flujo de armas en este país pues también
se ha congelado y creéis que Pakistán se
quedó sin nadie que le quisiera vender
armas pues no si algo nos enseña la vida
es que cuando una puerta se cierra se
abre una ventana y en este caso a
Pakistán le cerró la puerta a Estados
Unidos pero china le abrió una ventana
de oportunidad Y esto no nos extraña
para nada porque la historia que
comparten es casi de película de
Hollywood atentos
[Música]
china al rescate
en abril de 2015 el presidente de China
visitó por primera vez como jefe de
estado a Pakistán sus palabras antes de
visitar al país Aliado al mejor amigo
del gigante chino dejan bastante claro
lo que china siente por Pakistán fijaos
cuando era joven escuché muchas
historias conmovedoras sobre Pakistán y
la amistad entre nuestros dos países por
nombrar solo algunas me enteré de que el
pueblo pakistaní se esforzaba por
construir su hermoso país y de que
Pakistán abrió un corredor aéreo para
que china llegara al mundo y apoyó a
China para que recuperara su legítimo
puesto en las Naciones Unidas estas
historias me han dejado una profunda
impresión espero con interés mi próxima
visita de estado a Pakistán sillín 2015
y es que las relaciones entre chinos y
lo que llamamos pakistaníes Data de
antes mucho antes de la época colonial
británica en el sur de Asia pero la
verdadera amistad entre China y Pakistán
no empezó hasta después de sus
independencias
[Música]
Pakistán fue uno de los primeros países
era china como nación además también
aceptó la delimitación de su frontera
norte que proponía china con Shin yang y
por si fuera poco china ha apoyado a
Pakistán en sus guerras contra la India
antagonista de ambos países recordáis
cuando os decíamos que en 1965 Estados
Unidos le cortó el Grifo de armas
Afganistán Pues bien china fue corriendo
a sustituir al Tío Sam y entre 1965 y
1933 el 60% de todas las armas que
importó Pakistán fueron chinas y aunque
hoy ya no se mantenga ese 60%. el 40% de
todas las armas que importa Pakistán
siguen viniendo del gigante asiático y
además es importante todo tanque vt4
vehículos aéreos no tripulados
submarinos cazas jf 17 vamos que sin
medias tintas y medias tintas porque su
comercio no solamente es de armas sino
de todo lo que os podéis imaginar
Pakistán forma parte del proyecto belt
and Road es decir la nueva ruta de la
seda China y China ha decidido premiar a
su fiel Aliado con la Joya de la corona
de esta iniciativa
[Música]
en 2015 China y Pakistán crearon un
corredor económico entre ambos países
aprovechando la situación geográfica
privilegiada de Pakistán con Costa en el
océano Índico haciendo frontera con el
mundo árabe y especialmente con Irán
china ve en Pakistán una oportunidad de
oro de hecho su proyecto estrella gira
en torno a una ciudad costera la ciudad
de guadar ya hemos hablado aquí de esta
ciudad y de su importancia para china
pero conviene refrescar los datos
guardar se encuentra en el sur de
Pakistán en la provincia de balochistán
su cercanía al estrecho de ormuz lo hace
un lugar perfecto para poder construir
un puerto que reciba todo tipo de
productos especialmente petróleo
recordad que el petróleo que compra
china pasa por aguas territoriales
indias en caso de conflicto India podría
cortar todo este tráfico colapsando a
China en pocos meses el puerto por lo
tanto es la pieza clave sobre la que
giran otros proyectos en la ciudad como
la construcción de un hospital rompeolas
o el siguiente paso principal la
construcción de un oleoducto un
oleoducto que conecte o a dar con China
y que deberá recorrer todo Pakistán de
norte a sur
pero no tan de fresa donde hemos dicho
que está esta ciudad en valochistan en
esa Región turbulenta donde está el
ejército de liberación de balochistan el
mismo que en abril de este mismo año
asesinó a tres ciudadanos chinos
[Música]
mis queridos amigos de visualpolitik
China no ha olvidado el terrorismo en el
país de hecho aunque varios paquetes
financieros que manda Pakistán estén
condicionados a la mejora de la economía
otros proyectos están condicionados a
una mejora de la seguridad y es que la
inseguridad ha sido lo que ha impedido
que muchos de estos proyectos chinos en
Pakistán avancen como deberían incluso
los chinos llegaron a pedir que
amurallaran toda la ciudad de guadar Y
si a este problema de seguridad lo
unimos la de crepita economía de
Pakistán al borde del colapso financiero
y sin poder pagar sus deudas tenemos un
escenario de muy alto riesgo para china
está claro que Pakistán ha encontrado en
China a su mejor salvavidas y que china
vea Pakistán como una de sus mejores
amigos sino el mejor desde
reconocimiento mutuo desde el principio
a militar y económico por eso Pese a que
Pakistán tenga el clima más hostil
posible la inversión china está
apostando tan fuerte por el país pero la
pregunta ahora es para vosotros creéis
que china logrará que el terrorismo en
Pakistán desaparezca conseguirá Pakistán
levantar cabeza con china durará esta
bonita amistad que tienen estos dos
países o conseguirá accidente seducir a
Pakistán podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y darle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]